bodyguard concludes its first season
with the terrific ending that's full of
twists and turns
we finally have answers to all of the
questions that have been building up
over the series and throughout this
video I will be discussing the program's
ending in full detail there will be
heavy spoilers so it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you get
to see the final episode without the way
I'm definition and I ruin the show so
you don't have to in the final episode
of bodyguard
we learn that Nadia Ali was the true
mastermind behind the events that took
place in the show after david prevented
her suicide bombing in episode 1 Nadia
enacted a plan to ruin his life and get
revenge
David unwittingly showed her pictures of
his family in episode 1 and this is how
the film was able to organize an attack
on his children's school she was also
able to build a multitude of bombs
before her incarceration including the
bomb at st. Matthew's College and
David's suicide vest
with the help of Luke akin who had his
own reasons for assassinating Julia she
was able to bring her plan to fruition
when asked why she carried out this
merciless destruction of David's life
and the British government
Nadia stated that he thought so little
of me he showed me pictures for him I
was a weak woman I remembered everything
he told me about his children their
names their ages and from prison I was
able to inform my organization Nadia was
a very calculating villain who was
willing to work with non-believers in
order to enact her plan she clearly
wanted to show that she was just as
valuable in the war as a man would be
and was perhaps angered by the fact that
David became a bodyguard in order to
protect women once more when Nadia
believed that they were strong enough on
their own we discover Luke Aikins
motives for the attack were not personal
and that he merely killed Julie as a way
to divert laws that may be used again
steam in the future Julia wanted to pass
the legalization our IPA 18 which would
transfer powers from the police to
security services Luke had used bribery
and extortion to avoid prosecution from
the law but knew that the new
legislation would make the improve
security services more difficult to get
around Luke's first attempt on Julia's
life was when he armed David's army
friend Andy with a sniper rifle
however after this failed he saw more
extreme measures we discovered that
there were two inside moles working
against Julia
the first being Chanel who was fired
early on for being terrible at her job
and the latter being Lorraine Craddock
the rain' chose David as Julia's
bodyguard due to the fact that he would
make the perfect fall guy
Lorraine shared Julia's itinerary with
Luke so that he could place the sniper
Andy on the route her car would travel
and also helped to arrange the bombing
in the bombing we learned that too here
was an unlucky bystander who just
happened to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time but this provided the perfect
cover for Craddock was also putting
suspicion towards David Chanel would lay
a lure David into a trap by providing
information on Luke and this all tied
into David's master plan to clear his
name whilst David's plan could have been
executed better the character still
managed to clear his name by the show's
close strapped with a suicide vest and
dumped into the street
David had become the perfect fall guy
due to the lies that he had told about
knowing Andy and it tense standoff with
the police David revealed that he did in
fact know Andy and that he had also
stashed away information in his flat
that would clear his name this forced
the insiders and conspirators to journey
to his flat but due to the booby trap
that David itself earlier he was able to
prove there was more to his story than
the police knew about David managed to
disarm the suicide vest with help from
the police and cleared his name to
further prove his innocence and catch
the real culprits David bolted across
the Kappa door broke into Chanel's flat
used her to get to Luke and
identified the ranked Roddick as the
inside woman David cleared his name and
the three culprits were jailed the PM
was forced to resign due to information
that Julia possessed on them being
leaked by an Sampson and Mike Travis
remain Lee government to kick RI pa-18
into the long grass putting power back
into the hands of the police so what did
you think of bodyguard did he guess the
twist and what would you like to see in
the second series if there ever is one
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of television recently I
discussed the ending of the new Netflix
show maniac so make sure you check that
video next linked at the end of this one
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]